regardez sur les portes direct
bon là je suis colère
c'est mon coup de gueule
c'est une information il y a énormément
fait parler aujourd'hui concerne les
Restos du Coeur vous savez l'association
est actuellement en grande difficulté
financière parce que Patrice Drouet le
président bénévole des restes du coeur a
déjà annoncé qu'il devait réduire leur
nombre de bénéficiaires pour cet hiver
et que l'association risquait de fermer
ici trois ans si rien n'était mis en
place tout le monde a entendu le message
et cet appel n'est pas tombé dans
l'oreille ni d'une sourde ni d'un seau
en l'occurrence Bernard Arnault club le
plus riche du monde
ça va rien c'est une fois c'est lui une
fois c'est la musk voilà il s'appelle
alors c'est qui c'est toi dans
il a dansé donné 10 millions d'euros
pour l'association le gars personne lui
a demandé il a entendu ça il dit je vais
donner 10 millions et il y a des
gugusses les bras le liner c'est moi qui
l'ai fait là le liner un coup de gueule
notamment de la France insoumise que 10
millions d'euros le gars il donne pas il
aurait rien donné on aurait dit pourquoi
il donne pas l'iPhone 10 millions
d'euros tout le monde le tombe dessus
non mais je vous jure non mais c'est les
gars c'est quand même des gugus c'est
pas possible donc je vais revenir là
dessus j'allais dire ce que vous en
pensez petit récap et après on en parle
le gars il a donné 10 millions d'euros
et il a des gars ils viennent en plateau
là j'ai vu là les bons parlent les mecs
de la LFI l'année dernière oui mais
c'est l'admissible il a donné 10
millions d'euros qu'est-ce que tu as
donné toi qu'est-ce que tu as donné quoi
tu as donné quoi toi bah voilà regardez
c'est une annonce qui a bouleversé les
Français ce week-end les Restos du Coeur
pourraient mettre la clé sous la porte
d'ici 3 ans créant en 1985 par
l'humoriste Coluche l'association qui
vient en aide au plus démunis se
retrouvent aujourd'hui en grande
difficulté à cause de l'inflation on
arrive plus à manger normalement parfois
on se prive même du repas de midi très
vite des personnalités ont décidé de
leur venir en aide si le gouvernement et
la grande distribution ont promis de se
mobiliser l'un des hommes les plus
riches du monde a lui aussi répondu à
l'appel du président de l'association la
famille de Bernard Arnault qui a décidé
de verser en urgence 10 millions d'euros
mais certains notamment au sein de la
France insoumise se sont montré
critiques envers son geste a ramené à sa
fortune personnelle c'est l'équivalent
pour quelqu'un qui gagne le SMIC d'un
don de 30 centimes d'euro alors Bernard
Arnault donne 10 millions d'euros au
Resto du Coeur comprenez-vous les gugus
qui le critiquent
on a vu l'extrait d'un déguste là on va
voir d'autres il y a Mathilde panneau
donc qui refuse de dire merci à la
famille Arnaud elle nous explique
pourquoi regardez Mathilde panot porte
bien son nom merci à 10 millions d'euros
qui sont donnés au resto du coeur si ce
gouvernement se décidait finalement ce
pourquoi nous allons nous battre dans le
budget à enfin taxer les riches de ce
pays qui s'engraissent pendant que la
majorité sociale du pays est en train de
s'appauvrir et bien nous serions dans
une toute autre situation
ma petite panneau qui porte bien son nom
elle tombe toujours dedans
mais ma petite panneau elle sera Bernard
Arnault déjà c'est des milliers
d'emplois mais des millions d'emplois
c'est des impôts et on a donné on a dit
qu'on va y donner
contribuable de France exactement
personnel et professionnel ma petite
panneau la donneuse de leçons qu'est-ce
qu'elle a fait elle a juste acheté un
pupitre voilà merci alors il y a Thomas
porte aussi voilà qui refuse aussi de
dire merci les gars tu leur donnes 10
millions d'euros ils disent pas merci
mais eux ils font rien eux ils sont
tranquilles ils vont ils vont manger
tranquille
vous dit pas merci non je dis pas merci
je vais expliquer pourquoi si on le met
en parallèle d'un Français moyen qui
gagne le SMIC c'est l'équivalent d'un
don de 30 centimes d'euro voilà ce qu'a
versé la famille de Bernard Arnault au
resto du coeur non c'est pas assez
donné l'équivalent lui il a donné 30
centimes déjà il lui donne même pas ses
crevard il donne même pas 30 censure
c'est insupportable en fait qui dit ça
mais pourquoi ils sont en train de se
saboter
une sortie une ânerie en fait c'est
hallucinant quand même sort de de
Gilles Verdez pour c'est il va voir
comment il va défendre ses amis
on vit dans un pays où il y a plein de
gens qui rêvent secrètement d'être
milliardaire et c'est même personne
passe leur temps à leur taper dessus
s'ils donnent rien c'est des connards
s'il donne c'est des opportunistes ou
des radins mais qui donne déjà eux un
euro 10 euros 100 euros il donne rien du
tout et rien du tout qui a des gens ils
donnent rien du tout voilà heureusement
qu'il y a des gens comme Bernard Arnault
pour soutenir ses associations puisque
la solidarité nationale ne suffit même
plus il faut faire appel à Bernard
Arnault ou à l'équipe de France ou à des
personnalités pour sauver ses
associations
à leur 30 centimes parce qu'en fait ils
sont donnés le mot c'est les gars de la
France insoumise la manuel Bompard qui a
dit la même chose donc ils à mon avis
ils ont dû faire les calculs c'est
marrant tout ça ils étaient tous comme
des fois en réunion ils ont un truc de
foulée vous partez allez vous partez en
plateau les gars hein
vous savez que l'équivalent du don qui a
donné Bernardo si vous le revenez
ramenez à sa fortune personnelle c'est
l'équivalent pour quelqu'un qui gagne le
SMIC d'un don de 30 centimes d'euro donc
si vous voulez si vous voulez madame je
peux dire je peux dire merci bravo mais
c'est pas mon sujet regardez-moi ces
gugusse alors oui euh après j'en ai
d'autres allez on va voir tiens mon ami
regardez Alexis aussi il a dit Alexis
regardez Monsieur Bernard Arnault va
donner
0,0
4% de sa fortune personnelle c'est comme
si quelqu'un qui avait un petit bas de
laine de 10000 euros donner 4 euros et
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que nous avons
besoin de plus de solidarité la
République c'est la solidarité d'accord
le système caritatif avant la République
sa fortune personnelle est taxée et est
imposée à 18% ce qui est extrêmement
faible il a toute une série on le sait
très bien de d'argent placé dans des
paradis fiscaux n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi c'est dingue c'est n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi c'est insupportable alors
il y a des députés au Bono bien sûr
qu'il y a qui a mis son grain de sel
aussi pareil même discours il y a Louis
Boyard bien entendu
merci
que la France insoumise
elle ne défend pas les idées de gauche
qui devraient être des idées de partage
des idées de redistribution donc elle
est perdue dans ses propres arguments il
y a une haine du riche qui est
développée en France moi je comprends
pas j'ai vécu cinq ans aux États-Unis
quand tu t'assois dans un avion et que
tu es à côté d'un mec qui a réussi la
discussion s'engage autour de combien tu
fais combien tu fabriques en anglais
c'est make c'est combien tu fabriques
comment ça va mec
et donc mais non mais c'est une culture
la culture c'est combien tu fabriques
combien tu fais pour l'économie et en
France on a tout un tas de titres qui
t'expliquent que bah non c'est jamais
assez c'est il y a toujours des aigri
moi je trouve ça terrible mais qu'est-ce
que tu penses à des mecs de la France
insoumise qui fracasse Bernard Arnaud
qui a donné 10 millions d'euros comme ça
du jour au lendemain il a dit je donne
10 millions
c'est pire que des gugusse ces mecs là
je te dis ils sont à court d'arguments
ils sont gênés par le par la générosité
oui effectivement donc aujourd'hui ils
savent plus quoi dire j'aimerais qu'on
ait un autre gugus dans un instant qui
perdaise et je pense qu'il est d'accord
avec ses amis oui mais je suis d'accord
je vais te dire là tu vas m'insupporter
et fais-le et tu vas me supporter c'est
un support non mais c'est insupportable
mais non mais je suis pas que tu
pourrais le répondre
non mais je te le dis Pascal alors deux
choses moi je pense que c'est de la com
de la part de les filles il y a très peu
d'actualité en ce moment donc sortir une
punchline oui mais à un moment il vaut
mieux il vaut mieux fermer sa gueule que
dire des conneries voilà je suis dans
les sondages hein
faut peut-être le rappeler ce qui nous
regardent Bernard Arnault on dit c'est
l'homme le plus riche du monde il en
dispose pas de son argent de la totalité
de de son argent on voit la tête de Mia
10 millions d'euros c'est une somme
considérable l'État vers 15 millions
d'euros de son côté aussi au resto du
coeur et totale énergie qui est la
première capitalisation
j'aimerais les gars Delphine vous êtes
d'accord non moi aussi je veux défoncer
Gilles si c'est possible
laisse-le parler laisse-le parler et
apprends le défonce pas on va laisser le
gugusse parler là donc toi tu es
d'accord avec tous ceux qui critiquent
Bernard Arnault qui a donné 10 millions
d'euros déjà qu’est-ce que tu as donné
toi qu'est-ce que tu as donné toi partez
le son toi aussi hein qu'est-ce que tu
as donné à part là-bas que je t'ai donné
à Fatou qu'elle t'a donné
merci de me donner la parole je vais
vous dire moi quand je donne j'en fais
pas état sur la place publique c'est ça
qui me gêne ah c'est ça qui me gêne et
les autres à donner et d'ailleurs le
fait qu'il l'ait dit le fait qu'il ait
dit ça fait boule de neige ça fait un
appel d'air c'est vraiment tu vois
Gilles franchement
c'est quand même beaucoup
on a compris oui non mais alors voilà
donc déjà là j'ai l'argument derrière ça
fait boule de neige tout le monde a
donné donc déjà ton premier argument
allez à la poubelle allez merci deuxième
je suis pas d'accord avec eux sur la
manière dont ils disent parce que c'est
un peu méprisant non mais moi la
médiatisation Megève alors aussi de la
défiscalisation on sait très bien que
quand
même on sait rien du tout pour lui il a
déjà répondu
fiscalisation voilà
même si c'est de la défiscalisation on
s'enfuit il est en train de sauver les
restos du cœur et on a tous envie que
les restos du cœur continuent enfin
franchement plus de gens qui ont besoin
de la folie quand je donne je le dis pas
je vous le dirai
pourquoi il le dit quoi c'est un appel
d'air ça va faire autre chose mais oui
pourquoi il le dit comme ça c'est ça qui
me gêne mais on sent que c'est le gros
français
je te connais en fait quand tu as plus
d'arguments tu avances ton visage tu
crois que tu vas me faire peur tu fais
peur à personne
fait peur à personne
on sait pas la peine de t'avancer pas la
peine de t'avancer et de relire la même
chose que je peux te il y a deux minutes
terminé fin du débat on t'a expliqué
pourquoi il avait médiatisé le truc
merci Delphine en fait j'ai dit trois
mots
heureusement qu'aujourd'hui il y a
encore des hommes riches des gens qui
ont réussi leur vie qui ont trouvé le
bon filon qui acceptent de rester en
France avec leur entreprise donc ça déjà
c'est quelque chose il faut quand même
soutenir ces gens-là ensuite s'il
n'avait pas donné le gars il dormirait
tranquille on parlerait même pas lui
sauf qu'il a donné et que tout le monde
dit proportionnellement c'est vraiment
indécent c'est comme 30 centimes sur un
salaire sauf que dans la réalité de la
réalité c'est quand même 10 millions
exactement
eux les premiers sont des riches à une
autre échelle moi ce que j'aime pas que
ça soit c'est qu'ils passent leur temps
à taper sur les riches mais les députés
la France insoumise qui gagnent 6000
balles Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a une
fortune supérieure à un million d'euros
bah rend l'argent mec si tu voyages mais
tout le monde met tout le monde mais
bien sûr qu'il prend la business sur lui
Mélenchon il y a une photo de lui en
train de Voyer ton visage il dit je
voyage en business class parce que c'est
confortable etc bah fait croquer
non non mais je te le dis Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vidéo de lui dire je voyage
toujours en business class vous
comprenez bien sûr piquer mais c'est une
immense hypocrisie enfin je veux dire
ils sont totalement à court d'arguments
pardon j'ai le mais c'est quand tu
commences à m'emmerder
c'est mon petit protégé vas-y bravo
Jacques vas-y
des choses agréable lundi mais alors là
je crois que c'est fini non non mais je
le fais pas j'adore mais je ne fais pas
exprès mais attends juste débattre quand
même Bernard Arnault d'être le sauveur
de la non mais c'est des Restos du cœur
je comprends que certains
d'ailleurs tout le monde s'est réveillé
quand bien même ce serait vraiment se
réveiller avant lui Gilles quand bien
même ce serait de la défiscalisation
mais Gilles pourquoi il y a cette
culture là qui consiste à
systématiquement vouloir critiquer des
gens qui gagnent de l'argent qui ont du
succès et qui donne de l'argent à des
gens qui en ont besoin est-ce que c'est
un problème la société elle restera
[Applaudissements]